one tweet what were you doing at the
moment that made you want to send up
that sweet that day there just seems to
be a lot of negativity so I thought this
would be a nice little thing about
acceptance from a Kinley's grandparent
so I asked can we if it all right if I
just put this out there I didn't really
expect it to sort of flow off the way it
did to have something put out there like
explicitly like yes like we accepted
like we love our child and our daughter
it's really yeah that is really lovely
over fourteen thousand likes
four thousand retweets and Counting this
one little tweet has really opened up
the transgender discussion and for Colin
and Kinley it all started last April it
was fairly straight forward ever there
were like challenges that came with it I
mean I know there there was like some
difficulty around by getting used to the
name change and your name I understand
is the family event I said to my parents
I would love to know like what names you
like and what names you would give me
now and they came back to me I think the
next day of a list of about 20 names
slowly we had it down to about 5 and
just slowly got to I don't know there's
something about Kinley this is my child
it's that same person with a new coat
and you know you when you have a child
all you want for your child is for them
to be safe to be happy and to be better
than you now there's a lot of people who
are watching right now
and if there are people who are going
through the same thing kids that are
watching what would your message be for
them
gender is self determined you're the
only person who gets to make that call
and there will be doubt there will be
days where you struggle but just know
that all that matters is how you feel
and how you perceive yourself and how
you know yourself and that's all that
really matters and screw the rest